the busiest Beaver award goes to Phyllis
Lapin yeah
yeah way to go Phyllis nice work per
usual this says bushiest beaver
I told him busiest idiots it's fine but
we can fix it we'll fix it up you don't
have to display that hey Meredith I
talked to you privately for a second
about what your outfit
what's wrong with my oven
you might consider pulling it down a
touch
finding a blue high a bunch of fruits
you know Oscar's allowed to wear sandals
but I'm not allowed into a shoes is that
the how it goes Meredith your boob is
out fine no no
all day
happy
oh
Toby Toby
oh hey hey no time to chat well we were
just looking for Ryan so he's not here
hey you looking for me oh yeah we were
we were just gonna say hi so hey
no you weren't no we weren't you wanted
to have sex in my office nope definitely
not it's it's it's cool just um try to
put everything back where you found it
uh text me when you're finished up I'll
be out here hey you don't have the
that was so embarrassing I'm gonna die
yeah that was really rough
let me make something clear
Jim and I have never and will never have
sex in the office nope because the
office isn't what I'd consider a
romantic place
besides we have something those other
people don't have which is a home and a
bed
not a shower
a matter of fact
I printed out 10 ways to induce labor
and I'm thinking we just do the opposite
of those things and we can slow down
your labor Aaron read the first one
um stimulate the nipples okay nobody
tucked Pam's nipples think of Pam's
nipples as Toby's grundle her shirt is
touching them maybe we should cut holes
in her shirt I have a shirt like that in
my car oh
okay uh the second one is walk around
we're already doing the opposite of that
perfect okay uh number three eat spicy
foods okay the opposite of that stick
spicy food up her butt nope if it makes
you feel any better I never had an
orgasm until I was 42 and then when I
did it lasted till I was 44. 43 was
I got nothing done
I think the old honor System was fine
for example I have never slept with an
employee and believe me I could have
like yeah Meredith no no Catherine
remember her remember how hot she was
she would have definitely slept with me
she wasn't that hot yes she was okay you
know what if Pam was a lesbian
what if she brought her partner in to
work would that be crossing the line no
what if they made out in front of
everybody well that would be at home and
I told everybody everything about it
okay I'm lost okay well then let's act
it out Pam you will be girl a and girl B
will be
okay use the doll
Pam
you know what
I love Phyllis
you know what else
I think she is gorgeous
I think she is an incredibly incredibly
attractive person
come on come on come on you don't have
to worry
I'm not worried to HR you know what the
only thing I am worried about
you're getting a boner
good work today everybody
all right girls break it up you're being
infiltrated
[__] in the hen house Cox in the hen
house don't say Cox
why
whoa
I didn't forget my keys I just didn't
want to make out with you in front of
the cameras
tiles all the way down
now they can't hear us at all oh good
we're totally alone
here they come what no just kidding
just kidding seriously though that's
enough
why don't you clap out with the broccoli
oh great I have to cover him
do you think they dined and dashed
because I didn't die
so yeah maybe they just dashed
I thought we were having a nice time we
were
empty mine too
foreign
okay
[Music]
okay then
so where were we Boeing yep yep yep the
PDA yes the freaking PDA thank you
I mean I'm thrilled for them no one is
more thrilled for them than I am yes
absolutely but it's totally
inappropriate yeah it's a little much
obviously so happy for them both yeah I
don't know guys I for one enjoy watching
them no because it happens can I finish
is that okay
I was saying
I enjoy watching them because it makes
me horny are you still having
intercourse with her
what is wrong with you she is engaged
did you ever have intercourse in this
office
are you serious
oh
where
Dwight
seems like you already know where
Jim would you prefer a nature metaphor
or a sexual metaphor oh God nature
please when two animals are having sex
one of them is communicating a message
to the other nothing is even this isn't
very helpful you're going to want to
hear the sexual metaphor was that not
that oh life is sex and all sex is
competition and there are no rules to
that game
that wasn't so perverted now was it
oh
she's doing it again
Phyllis has gotten into audiobooks and
lately she's been listening to 50 Shades
of Gray which if you don't know what it
is it's a book about a um it's porn yeah
seriously
this is unacceptable it's officially a
hostile work environment
somebody just needs to get our attention
tell us not okay to do this in public be
careful I pulled my mom's dog off a
pillow once and I got bit just ignore
certain little she'll finish oh
what Phyllis is masturbating in the
office right now as we speak can we skip
the color commentary and just have Andy
go out there and fire her he can't do
that it turns out just she's allowed to
have feelings of sexual arousal doesn't
become a violation until she physically
acts on it
why is Phyllis so aroused she's
listening to Fifty Shades of Gray
well there you go that's my weekend okay
you are useless I'll take care of this
what the hell it's okay guys she's no
longer horny
excuse me dirty birdie
you can have this back at the end of the
day